(heavy footsteps)
♫ Maybe, crazy ♫
- Just put on some
Chance The Rapper
and Saba and I'll be fine.
I'm all about Chicago.
Boulder, Colorado baby.
Boulder's pretty.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- I can't hear my volume
because I got
Chance The Rapper banging.
We could fill up the
next hundred episodes
of DailyVee DRock,
with my weaknesses.
Here are the current
vulnerabilities cause it's summer.
A little more wine than normal,
like, summer is when
white wine and rose's
more interesting to me.
Actually one the interesting
things about how I roll is,
how little I focus
on the weaknesses.
Bread is a weakness right now.
Bread has been a new vulnerability.
Like, I'm weird-ed out by how
much I want bread at meals.
Came out of nowhere.
DRock just said to me, "Hey
let's focus on weaknesses."
"I just saw you do that call about,
"last couple weeks of your health,
"like some of the things
that you're worried about."
Like, I'll never eat
a bag of potato chips,
or like, I don't eat
15 Oreos, you know?
Oh, there is one thing.
Tell Lizzy to stop buying those
chocolate covered pretzels.
That's killing me, I've
eaten a bunch of those
in the last month and they're
the best thing I've ever had.
You know, it's funny, I'm
so focused on my strengths.
I'm so focused on the
opportunities at hand,
I'm so focused on the positivity,
the optimism of the game,
that this is actually gonna be the most
challenging episode for me.
To almost like,
fester up weaknesses,
or think about things to
say to bring some value
to this episode.
Super difficult, like, you know,
that's just hard for me to do.
I'm just not really good at
respecting my weaknesses.
I'm not good at dwelling
at my weaknesses,
I'm not good at
acknowledging my weaknesses.
Why?
Everybody else is
doin' that for you.
I think, to win, you need
to be your biggest fan.
You need to focus
on your strengths.
I'll appease you on
this episode, DRock,
and give you some weakness talk.
But, it's not gonna be that good.
And it's not gonna be that easy.
And it's surely not gonna
come up so easily for me.
Because there's a
real part of me,
that cuts that cancer out.
We've all got 'em.
We've all got our
weaknesses, everybody.
I just think the people that win,
respect their strengths more.
♫ Listen up ♫
(light music)
Facebook live, homies.
It's Gary, but you know that.
About to head down to Denver.
And give a keynote at
Denver Startup Week.
- [Voiceover] Warm round of applause
for Gary Vaynerchuk,
come on welcome to Gary.
(applause)
- Good morning, or afternoon.
Thank you so much
for having me.
Really, what I'm gonna
talk to you about,
is attention today,
and even then,
I realize, innately,
this a six year old,
this is not something you read
in a business book at six.
I realize that people's
eyes and attention
is what I was interested in.
I didn't need to pour
the lemonade stand,
especially if I could get
Robby Turnick to do it.
I needed to figure out
how to get people to stop.
Think about how
sick of a child I was.
As a six year old,
it was interesting to me,
to sit at the corner of a
street, and watch people drive
and try to figure out which
tree or pole was smarter
to put the sign up on
because that's where
they were looking.
And that is really, basically,
the thing that
I most care about.
Have you found the
people in your life
that have already
won and are good?
That's what I am, I'm good.
I don't need anything
from you guys.
I just don't need
anything from you guys.
I don't want anything.
I want you to listen.
And then go have
happiness and success,
whether that's work-life balance,
whether that's honing
your skiing skills,
whether that's building a
million dollar business,
I don't care, I don't
need you to be a hustler,
I don't need you to
be an entrepreneur,
be a business man.
I don't need you to do anything.
I need you to pay me back
by going out
and then doing something
with what I'm giving you.
Paying back the attention
I'm taking from you,
paying yourself back.
You know, giving me the
feeling that I'm bringing value
to the world,
by actually doing something
about what I have to say.
That's what I'm doing
with my attention,
what are you doing
with your attention?
The one thing that
ties us all together,
everybody in this room,
the one thing that
ties us all together,
is before you tell me
how great your agency is,
or how great your service is,
or how great your startup is,
or how great your juice is,
or how great your
new sneaker is.
Before you tell me, and the
world, how great your thing is,
you need my attention.
- Good job man.
- Thank you brother, it's a lot of fun.
Thank you my man, you
did a great job as well.
Yes.
(laughter)
I'm about to go on stage
and DRock's like,
"Uh", I had a meeting
this morning really early,
so I had to work out right
after that, before I came here.
And I just didn't notice
that I put it inside-out,
and I was about to go on
stage, and DRock's like,
"Your shirt's inside" and
I'm like, "Too late now."
(laughter)
I realize what's
going on here.
One life,
I realize that I'm living,
like this is our only at
bat, and most of you aren't.
People fuckin'
walking around here
like they're comin' back.
People fuckin' walking around here
You're not comin' back.
I appreciate that I'm
a doer, I love doing.
I believe in doing.
There's not a lot of animals
running around out there
that have built two 50 million
dollar plus businesses.
There's plenty people bigger
than me, better than me,
winners than me.
Respect, they deserve it.
But there's not a lot
of people running around
with the results.
Definitely not, and
this is the punch line.
Definitely not a lot of
people running around
with the results that I've had.
That are equally trying to
give as much time as possible
to their audience so
that they can taste
the fruits of that as well.
Not a lot of people
with those results.
That are obsessed, with you
having those results too.
I just want you to
maximize what you got,
and I want you to try.
The thing that cripples me,
is the people that aren't trying.
Out of fear, out of laziness,
out of being unlucky,
with parents that
didn't support them.
Being unlucky growing
up in a neighborhood
that wanted to tear them down
instead of building them up.
So I'm out here, feeling guilty
because I had it so good,
with my mama and my daddy,
that I want to give that to you.
If I can be that random dude,
that's your mentor from afar,
that you've never met, like
so many of you have said.
- I just want to say, GaryVee, yo.
I'm sittin on the couch,
and I'm bein' lazy,
watchin' Facebook.
And I come across your video,
and it makes me get up and move.
Makes me go and
do something with it.
You're my mentor from
afar, I appreciate it.
Hell yeah.
- Thank you for helping us.
- That makes me super happy,
man, that's awesome brother.
And that gives you the
opportunity to have something
good happen in your life.
I'm super fuckin' interested,
like, that's legacy baby.
Legacy isn't me making six
billion or seven billion,
legacy is thousands, and I
mean, hundreds of thousands
of people e-mailing me
and telling me that
their lives are better
because their dad or mom
got motivated by something
I did and went on
and built something bigger and
better and meaner and leaner.
And better for them.
I want legacy.
- My dad got me into you
back when you were doing
Wine Library TV.
- Is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You know what drives
me? You know what I want to do?
I want to fuckin' steal
legacy, I want legacy.
That's why I want it for you.
Like, my selfishness
brings you value.
Just the way to work it
out, it is what it is.
See ya.
(slow, brooding music)
- So nice to meet you.
- I'm gonna be at your funeral,
just want to let you know.
- I appreciate that man,
you know what I care about.
Thank you guys, nice
meeting you, take care.